foreign
so if we think of the deep ocean as
being this
dark
deep horrifying place at the bottom of
the earth it's easy to dismiss it as
something which is
out of sight and out of mind but myself
and colleagues have been there and I
think if we take some time
to think about the deep ocean as part of
our planet we all might want to protect
it as much as any other
marine environment let your imagination
tell you what a deep sea animal looks
like
the one that immediately flashes into
your head when you think deep sea you're
probably thinking something like this
and that is a real fish that's a real
animal from the deep sea now that's the
kind of image you're quite often
presented with in the media when we talk
about deep water animals but there's two
things wrong with that photograph
first one is a little bit misleading in
that those types of animals are
genuinely quite shallowish in the grand
scheme of things maybe a few hundred
meters certainly top thousand meters
the second thing that's a little bit
misleading is that they are normally a
bit that big
right so they're hardly that scary yeah
it's not going to come and get you is it
but We Are Forever being told that there
are monsters of the deep in a little
voice and aliens of the Abyss but when
you take a moment to think about the
technicalities of being an alien in
Abyss
the only alien in the deep sea are the
occasional human
because everything else belongs there so
I am proud to say I am an alien of the
Abyss
and I've been studying the deepest parts
of the ocean for about 20 years but more
recently we've been diving in a
submarine one of the questions you quite
often get asked when you tell someone I
own Tuesday I went to Ten Thousand Years
uh they say oh it's not scary
and that that is the important point
it's fear it's that thing that we have
in our heads that doesn't like being
underwater so if you think about what
the deep sea represents it's a physical
three-dimensional manifestation of two
of the things we hate the most and we
have a phrase for that we call it the
deepest darkest fears because we were
air-breathing mammals so we don't really
want to be on the war especially not
super deep and we were visually
orientated animals we like light so 11
kilometers underwater is something that
everyone goes Ah that's really deep and
horrible that's just frightening take
that 11 kilometers
and turn it on its side
right I reckon most people in the room
have traveled 11 kilometers today
and the other thing that we don't like
is the unknown
right and this is where we just get into
this whole relationship between reality
and what we're told on the TV
so on the TV we're quite regularly told
that we know more about the surface of
the Moon than we know about the deep sea
uh for stars
that quote goes back before the Apollo
missions and a time where we knew not
very much about the moon or the deep sea
so if you're on the surface and you're
looking out and you can see all these
lovely whales and dolphins and Squid and
jellyfish and all that stuff has to die
all that material all that lovely
organic matter sinks and where does it
sink it sinks down to deeper debts it
ends up in a place we call the abyss and
not the our best like they say on TV the
Abyssal Zone technically is or are debts
between three thousand and six thousand
meters okay relatively shallow in my
game but
all that lovely organic material comes
down and settled there and it gets eaten
by deep sea animals those two animals
are eating at the recycling it they're
borrowing it they're they're
incorporating into the food chain and
they incorporate it into the sediments
so these animals are essentially
gardening because if they didn't do that
these big vast Abyssal planes of the
planet would become big stagnant
horrible cesspits so the deep sea
animals are basically irrigating a big
chunk of the planet
and I see a big chunk
the Abyssal zones account for
about 70 of the planet
let's take a bit of a journey a descent
into the deep sea how do we know where
to dive how do we know where we are ever
because we're always being told
that's true we've always been told that
we haven't mapped the oceans a certain
amount of seafloor has been seen with a
naked eye I took that on my phone
so it wasn't about I was seeing it at
the same time so I still can't and
there's a certain percentage which has
been mapped or or surveyed by remote
systems
so this is about 2 000 meters deep and
about 20 of the planet has been mapped
in pretty high resolution using
Acoustics this is a huge big change
running off north of New Zealand
well basically they have been mapped it
all depends on what resolution okay so
there's some places where we know where
absolutely every little Nuki cranny
might be there are no more Mariana
finches to be found imagine we're in our
submarine This Is Us diving in the in
the submarine see it's very spacious it
has all the latest mod cons the sunlight
diminishes very very quickly in the top
maybe in the first two minutes it goes
that fast and you see that it does get
dark very quickly and as we descend down
through the water column we've always
been told that the water's very very
cold very very icy cold water and yeah
it's called
it's not anywhere near as cold as
most if not all of the winters I've ever
endured until moving to Australia
but it's about between one and two
degrees at the deepest point it's not
overly cold but those water masses deep
down are still moving they're still
ventilating they're still full of oxygen
and they're moving heat they're cooling
heat down from the atmosphere and the
surface waters and dissipating around
the planet as we go down to the bottom
of the Mariana Trench we now have
one ton per square centimeter of
pressure squeezing down on that titanium
ball or satin again it takes to a
certain person of a certain disposition
to do this stuff but you can't feel it
on the inside it's fine it's cold
outside and we're moving around and if
you look out the window we're looking
mostly at Mud
I think well imagine all that stuff
that's coming down from the surface all
that lovely organic matter it's carbon
it's taking carbon from the atmosphere
that's been absorbed into the ocean the
surface oceans it basically comes down
it sinks into the mud what happens to
the carbon
the bottom of the trenches the reason
why the trenches are so deep the reason
why they're 11 kilometers in some places
is because two tectonic plates hit each
other
sometimes they get pulled apart
sometimes just slide side by side but
the trenches are formed when one
tectonic plate hits another one and
drives it down into the Earth's mantle
hence you end up with something like
Mariana Trench now all that carbon
trapped in the sediment is then being
pushed back into the Earth's mantle the
deepest points on the planet are one of
the few places
we're actually disposing of carbon so
they're again performing a service to
the planet
so we're looking at the window what's it
look like
if you switch the lights on
right it looks like much
you have a lot of places are very flat
lovely luscious golden brown that's a
good healthy seafloor okay sometimes you
see some rocks and some rocky outcrops
you see cobbles and rocks and boulders
and all the rest of it sometimes it's a
bit crazy but none of these images look
that weird they look like something you
would expect to see if you were scuba
diving at night so the actual visual
landscape of the deepest places isn't
that strange either it's certainly not
something
you should fear
so let's get back to the monsters of the
deep
what do you reckon the deepest
tentacled animal is in the world being I
mean it's the tentacles that I've been
putting the fear of God into Sailors
since I don't know when
right imagine this thing coming up from
the deep sea so you're probably thinking
something a little bit like that
uh that's also a picture I took on my
phone recently but
it's been a funny old week but that's
that's the kind of image your
imagination puts into your head you
think deep sea technical the rally of
the matter is and I can proudly say that
I discovered the deepest octopus in the
world
it's the size of a puppy too
right it gets better its real name is
grim patricus which is a bit but
his common name is Dumbo octopus because
it has big dumbbell-like ears and this
lives at close to 7 000 meters in the
Indian Ocean that is your big scary
octopus that's coming to get you
so then we think about what's the
deepest fish look like
because they've got big horrible fans
right
and they're lurking in the darkness
coming to get you deepest fish in the
world is actually what we call snailfish
if anything it's a fit goofy looking
it's not really that threatening it's
not something you should fear they're
snuffling around they're looking for
stuff and they've got a little lies
they're actually gelatinous that's just
liver you can see on the side of its
body
they're very very soft bodied and what I
really love about the deepest fish in
the world is they're not really deep sea
fish they're actually a shallow water
family that has just radiated so most
snailfish are actually really shallow
you even get some in estuaries it's just
a fish that doesn't care it doesn't you
can't pigeonhole the snailfish you know
so
another animal a couple more animal that
we like our prawns right everyone loves
to eat a prawn that there is the last
the deepest of the big Crustaceans
that's a prawn and those are down to
nearly 8 000 meters and that wouldn't
look that out a place
in a fish market right it's nothing
weird about it either and one of my
personal favorites from the very very
very deepest points and we see these
bizarrely at the very deepest points and
multiple trenches we very rarely see
them anywhere else except for the most
extreme places and it's a type of
anemone
and it just kind of looked like white
flowers sort of floating in the in the
wind they're actually really beautiful
animals and they're living in
unbelievably or what we would class as
being extreme environments they have an
unpronounceable
uh Latin name which I maybe shouldn't
try but it's galafient I've done it so
thank you
I'm not doing it again though I've got
away with it once so
start to rethink the visual imagery and
the way in which the deep sea is in
reality and not the way we're told
it's time that we started thinking about
it the oceans generally is just one big
ocean from the surface to the bottom but
doesn't the ocean doesn't recognize
imaginary lines that we've drawn and
said that that sea that's deep sea so we
care don't care care don't care
right and that's actually what we do you
wouldn't
open the Amazon they say right everyone
we're going to catalog every known
species for the first 200 meters
everything after that are monsters of
the trees
fight because it's just dark and
horrible in there so let's not do that
but that is exactly what we do right now
to 70 of the planet
and that's what I find quite frustrating
another question I get asked sometimes
as well is what
other than the fear stuff
and the claustrophobia and the toilet
question and stuff like that it is you
know what's it like being in the bottom
of the sea looking at the window and
seeing stuff and I also actually find it
a genuinely
difficult question to answer because
it's
quite exciting afterwards you're all
like oh that was really exciting but at
the time it's it's quite humbling
because I think you're kind of aware of
find your seven miles on the wall and
one ton per square centimeter and all
that kind of if you do feel quite remote
but I just think you feel it's kind of
majestic I think it's it's certainly the
exact polar opposite of what you're told
it should be like it's not scary it's
peaceful and it's nice and there's
Beauty there and I think we need to
challenge the narratives that we're
given and change the story and start to
think of the deep sea as a place which
is fascinating it's wonderful it's
interesting and it's really really
important and only at that point if we
take all that on board will we ever
truly truly protect and live alongside
our oceans
thank you
[Applause]